hi I'm Charley day I'm going undercover
on the Internet and this is actually me
all right here we go this is a good one
Ruby says watching the video for
princess raspberry beret and the drummer
is definitely Charlie day and ice cream
this is true that that was me it's a
time work thing going on you cracked the
code and this is it just me or does
anyone else think Charlie day would make
a good Joker oh I would want to be the
Joker in the local dinner theater
musical version of Batman you know at
your local VFW controller did you say
something and it not sound mental okay
this is great
this person is anonymous but it says
this trying to have snake bites
I was watching SNL and it looked like he
did I rarely travel without snakes and
occasionally they get agitated but you
got it a lot of snake bites on me it's
Charlie day Jewish um
not gonna know good me maybe I should do
one of those 23 in these or something
and find out tomorrow
what are Charlie day is best films well
that's a highly subjective question but
since we're here promoting Hotel Artemis
I'll say how famous is Charlie day in
the USA probably the most famous person
in America what kind of American accent
is Charlie day half listen no accent
sorry
what are some biographical facts about
Charlie day I have some Italian until I
do that play to me and find out that
nope it's
I'm just I'm just Jewish from like
Russia or something I wish more Twitter
I wonder how Charlie is doing I hope
he's okay I'm doing pretty good
okay thanks for asking that was sweet
Caitlin said this I guess her New Year's
resolution is to try like hell not to
break off every single one of 13 on
Mary's going crackers birds don't have
teeth stupid bird Oh Glenn Glenn's got
one sad truth is when you have great ABS
the temptation to take a selfie while
pulling your shirt up will always be
there don't do it hang on so it's
Charlie they actually married to the
waitress in sunny uh yeah get with it
all right
Danny's foot I'm dating veto patrol
thought LA 2018 amen we get it it's your
foot I don't know I like it let's say I
don't like it that Merrimac you was
active in the on stagers Merrimack
student theatre organization he also
played varsity baseball for the Warriors
baseball team only he didn't play
varsity baseball but look a man if you
want to believe that I played college
baseball go for it next time we talk
let's have some deeper questions you
know I think we're just scratching the
surface of what we can find out about
and then I'll start asking you questions
[Music]